the Joe Rogan experience are you
surprised that with all your success and
all the attention that you've gotten
from your success as the only woman on
your level in in professional racing are
you surprised that more women aren't
entering in that you haven't like sort
of opened the door or do you think that
it's such a specialized and unique thing
to do that it's just not something that
a lot of women gravitate towards I used
to say that for a hundred men that came
through if you found a good you takes a
hundred to find a good one that comes
pretty quickly but to go through a
hundred women takes a lot longer because
there are some few of them there are
more coming through but I just think
that you know over time it just takes a
lot longer to find good ones but I don't
know I don't know I I think back to this
is my ego talking I think back to a long
time ago when Paul Newman was still
alive and we were on a late-night show
together probably Letterman and he was
asked before I went on he was the first
guest if there was going to be another
driver another girl that comes through
that compares to me and he said he
didn't think so maybe there won't be
maybe who knows he knew his
maybe I I mean you're unique I'm sure
there will be somebody I meet a lot of
women like you because of MMA oh there's
those savages that enter into MMA the
women that wind up fighting in MMA
there's a lot of them and I'm kind of
stunned at how many of them there are
but when I say they're like you I mean
they're bold powerful unique people that
are they just take wild chances I mean
the type of person that is like a Holly
Holm or someone like that so I think the
big difference lies and there are a lot
of people that are strong aggressive
confident you know assertive bold but to
then be able to keep it together and up
up above their shoulders that's another
that's the difference keep it together
in the pressure of a race yeah and the
pressure of whatever moment is have it
you're having whatever pressures are
being put on you
an event or for one I mean those are
that's really hard the right people
around you being able to filter the
and let in like keep the good keep your
own confidence up that's that's hard
that's the hardest part and then being
able to flip that switch when you're
performing to of course then to not have
doubts but more confidence I think
everything that you said would be
mirrored by what a woman who competes at
the very highest levels of MMA would say
hmm I think they would they would find
all those things to be factors you know
it's just I'm really stunned that you
literally are the only one I mean
there's that's uh that's an incredibly
rare position do you ever stop and think
about like what if you weren't there
it's not like it's forbidden for women
huh I never thought about it like that
I've mostly only thought about it from
the perspective of like have I thought
about what I've done in the sport
because stuff that people haven't done
before and usually my answer is is that
someday I'll look back and you know be
able to have a little bit more
perspective on it but right now I'm just
kind of in the middle of it but yeah
I've never thought about it like that
[Applause]